[Applause]
if you're associated with hip-hop and
you happen to be african-american and
you're seeing with the same group of
people there is this tendency to just
assume you for some reason are
considered part of gang activity and I
really feel like they're targets it's
got to the point now if there is a
hip-hop artists that's charged with a
crime anywhere in the United States I'm
gonna get a phone call I've been in this
criminal defense space for more than
three decades as my practice built up I
would occasionally represent somebody
famous I was fortunate enough to
represent Dennis Rodman safe Evans
Shaquille O'Neal and that eventually I
represented a guy named Ray trick Davis
to meet his range of Davis to the rest
of the world he's humane
getting him out on bond against all odds
it's getting him early released as that
was happening everybody else started
calling up one of the turning points for
me on many levels was dealing with the
case involving me ghost in South Georgia
amigos came in and they perform and law
enforcement went after them and they
went into their bus and they said there
were weeds and guns and blah blah blah
but law enforcement admittedly on the
stand said we went into their social
media and we saw all these things and we
were waiting for them law enforcement
they're just going to assume what they
see in YouTube and what they say an
Instagram is associated with criminal
conduct and they're gonna go out of
their way to try to take you down there
are issues that we have to contend with
with the case involving migos we
assembled 14 15 lawyers we have record
labels behind us we have somebody flying
in from a record label in Manhattan to
testify but then what about somebody in
Greenville Mississippi what about
somebody in Enid Oklahoma what about
people of color in those communities
that don't have the money to bring in a
legal team and don't have record label
standing behind them and it really
catalyzed my interest in addressing
racism and our criminal justice system
and mass incarceration I figure while
I'm up and about I can at least do
something to fight this system
you